Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Become for me a mirror of virtue, following in the footsteps of the crucified Christ. Bathe yourself in the blood of the crucified Christ, and thereby, for the length of your life, such is my wish, do nothing but seek out the crucified one, and make of him the great object of your longing, like a true bride, bought with the blood of the crucified Christ. For you can see with your own eyes that you are become his bride, and that he has married you, and every creature, not with a ring of silver, but with the very ring of his flesh.
感谢您收听《历史余温》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。请成为我美德的镜子，追随受难基督的脚步。沉浸在受难基督的血中，以此作为你一生的愿望，除了寻找那位受难者，别无他求，并让他成为你渴望的伟大目标，就像一位用受难基督的血买来的真正新娘。因为你可以亲眼看到，你已成为他的新娘，他已与你，以及每一个受造物结为连理，不是用银戒指，而是用他血肉的戒指。
Oh, depth and height of love unutterable, how profoundly you have loved this bride of yours, the human race. Oh, life through which all things do live, you have plucked humanity from the clasp of the devil, who previously had possessed it as his own, and made it one with your flesh through marriage your blood you have given us a pledge and by offering your body as a sacrifice you have made the necessary payment therefore my daughter drink deep of christ's blood so that's all that tom was a hammer horror film that was actually a letter in your notes it says written by to a nun so either written by or to a nun to a nun in pisa in pisa by the 14th century
哦，那不可言喻的爱之深广，你竟如此深切地爱着你的这位新娘——人类。哦，万物赖以生存的生命，你已将人类从魔鬼的掌握中夺回，魔鬼曾将其据为己有，你通过婚姻使人类与你的血肉合而为一，你赐予我们你的血作为誓约，并通过献出你的身体作为祭品，支付了必要的代价。因此，我的女儿，痛饮基督的血吧。汤姆，那全是关于一部汉默恐怖电影的内容吗？那实际上是你笔记里的一封信，上面写着是写给一位修女的，所以要么是写给一位修女的，要么是出自一位修女之手，写给14世纪比萨的一位修女。
saint catherine of siena now tom who is catherine of siena. Now, Tom, who is Catherine of Siena? Because I actually don't know. Well, you know that she's someone I've been wanting to do a podcast on for a long, long time. You have, and I've always said, why? Well, okay. She is a very, very significant figure in the church. And I'm aware that I'm not selling it there. But she had become a saint within less than a century of her life.
锡耶纳的圣凯瑟琳。现在，汤姆，谁是锡耶纳的凯瑟琳？因为我真的不知道。嗯，你知道她是我一直想做一期播客的对象，已经很久很久了。你确实想过，而我总是问，为什么？好吧，好吧。她是教会中一位非常、非常重要的人物。我知道我这么说可能吸引不了人。但她在去世不到一个世纪内就被封为圣徒了。
She is one of the very first female doctors of the church. So she's a figure of immense significance to the Catholic church. But I'm aware that that's probably not enough for you as a russet-coated yeoman of the shires with Protestant inclinations. I'm aware also that that letter that you've just read, that she wrote, full of stuff about drinking blood and washing in blood and everything. That again, this isn't entirely the kind of thing that say Oliver Cromwell would have gone for. You're a great hero. No, I can't imagine him liking that at all. And if it's not, you know, the kind of the slight hint of the vampiric in it.
她是教会最早的女性圣师之一。所以她对天主教会具有极其重要的意义。但我知道，对于你这样一个有着新教倾向的郡县乡绅来说，这可能还不够。我也知道你刚才读的那封她写的信，里面充满了关于喝血、在血中沐浴之类的内容。再说一次，这完全不是奥利弗·克伦威尔会喜欢的那种东西。你是个伟大的英雄。不，我无法想象他会喜欢这些。而且，如果这其中没有那种淡淡的吸血鬼意味的话。
I think what makes it even odder, perhaps to to the modern gaze is all that stuff about her marrying christ i mean people think of you know nuns as brides of christ catherine sienna is not a nun she literally means that she has married christ mrs christ right and she wears his his wedding ring and that very ring of his flesh i mean you know what that is talk me through it tom that that is his um circumcised foreskin okay and she's living in the 14th century is that right she's living in the 14th century so the very least it's quite withered no because it's miraculous it's miraculously preserved it's not only is it with it it's bleeding as well so right oh yeah there's blood on her finger so all of this may to us seem very weird. And I think that the weirdness
我认为，对于现代人的眼光来说，更奇怪的或许是关于她嫁给基督的所有那些事。我的意思是，人们认为修女是基督的新娘，但锡耶纳的凯瑟琳并不是修女，她是字面意义上嫁给了基督，基督夫人，对吧？她戴着他的结婚戒指，那正是他血肉的戒指。我的意思是，你知道那是什么吗？汤姆，给我讲讲。那是他……嗯，割礼后的包皮。好吧，她生活在14世纪，对吧？她生活在14世纪，所以至少那东西已经相当干瘪了。不，因为它是神迹，它被奇迹般地保存了下来。它不仅干瘪，而且还在流血。所以，是的，她的手指上有血。所以这一切对我们来说可能看起来非常怪异。我认为这种怪异
alone makes her a very interesting figure, but I would make much higher claims for her. So she lives through the 14th century, which is a period of great convulsions. And she is probably the most significant geopolitical player in this period. She's kind of Greta Thunberg cubed. Bigger than kings, Tom. She becomes a key player in attempting to resolve the fractures within Italy. And she has a seismic influence on the history of the papacy, which of course is very influential in medieval Europe. So I would say that she is one of the three or four most significant women to have lived in medieval Christendom in terms of her kind of influence. And on top of that-
本身就使她成为一个非常有趣的人物，但我会对她有更高的评价。她生活在14世纪，那是一个充满剧烈动荡的时期。她可能是这一时期最重要的地缘政治参与者。她简直是三次方版的格蕾塔·通贝里。比国王们还重要，汤姆。她成为解决意大利内部裂痕的关键人物。她对教皇制度的历史有着深远的影响，而教皇制度在中世纪欧洲当然非常有影响力。所以我认为，就其影响力而言，她是中世纪基督教世界中最重要的三四位女性之一。而且除此之外——
Top two or three biggest in history, let's say. Should we say that? I wouldn't go that far. But also all the stuff that she's going on there, particularly about food, about drinking blood, about all this kind of thing. She's fascinating as a mirror held up to male attitudes to women, how women see themselves, how women understand their relationship to God and their fellow human beings. I mean, she's a really, really, really interesting figure. So thank you for giving me the chance to make the case for this. Tom, I cannot wait. I am beside myself with excitement. So how do you want to start? A bit of background, perhaps?
可以说是历史上最伟大的两三个人物之一。我们要这么说吗？我不会走那么远。但她所做的一切，特别是关于食物、关于喝血、关于所有这类事情，作为一面映照男性对女性态度、女性如何看待自己、女性如何理解她们与上帝及同胞关系的镜子，她非常迷人。我的意思是，她真是一个非常、非常、非常有趣的人物。所以谢谢你给我机会为她辩护。汤姆，我迫不及待了。我兴奋得不能自已。那么你想怎么开始？先来点背景介绍吗？
I'd love a bit of background. Because the context is very important. So listeners may have heard the episodes we did on the Hundred Years' War in the 14th century. And we conveyed the sense then that the 14th century is not a great time to be alive. It's a very kind of turbulent period. So Catherine is born, as her name implies, in Siena in Italy on the 25th of March, 1347. And the backdrop to Europe is pretty terrible. There are famines. The weather has gone, the climate has kind of gone into decline. So the bad harvests, people are increasingly on the kind of the margins of famine.
我很想听听背景。因为背景非常重要。听众可能听过我们关于14世纪百年战争的剧集。我们当时传达了一种感觉，即14世纪并不是一个美好的时代。这是一个非常动荡的时期。所以凯瑟琳正如她的名字所暗示的那样，于1347年3月25日出生在意大利的锡耶纳。欧洲的背景相当糟糕。发生了饥荒。天气已经变了，气候已经开始恶化。所以收成不好，人们越来越处于饥荒的边缘。
North of the Alps in France, a hundred years war is starting to rage. You're starting to get those free companies, you know, the kind of bodies of men at arms and archers who are starting to kind of strip the French countryside bare. And there is a risk, you know, and it's a risk that will turn out to be a very live one, that they might start to cross the Alps and come into Italy. And if you are a devout Christian, which most people in Christendom in this period are, there is the spectacle of what is called the Babylonian captivity of the papacy. So basically the papacy, which as listeners
在阿尔卑斯山以北的法国，百年战争开始肆虐。你开始看到那些自由佣兵团，你知道，那些武装人员和弓箭手组成的团体，开始把法国乡村洗劫一空。而且存在一种风险，而且这种风险后来证明是非常现实的，他们可能会开始越过阿尔卑斯山进入意大利。如果你是一个虔诚的基督徒，而这一时期的基督教世界大多数人都是如此，那么就会看到所谓的教皇“巴比伦囚虏”的景象。所以基本上，教皇制度，正如听众
will know, is based in Rome. In the 14th century, it's migrated to the city of Avignon in southern France. It's not actually a part of the kingdom of France, but it has come massively under French influence. So it was a French Pope who kind of left Italy behind, moved to Avignon. And Avignon has become a kind of, well, they call it Babylonian captivity because Avignon seems a place of enormous wealth and depravity. So there are kind of great gardens and banqueting halls, and the Pope even has his own private steam room. And so there's a feeling that the Pope shouldn't be in this kind of place of luxury. He should be back in Rome. The Papal Palace in Avignon, for those people who haven't been is an absolutely splendid building i mean it's a
所知，总部设在罗马。在14世纪，它迁移到了法国南部的阿维尼翁市。它实际上不是法兰西王国的一部分，但它已经深受法国影响。所以是一位法国教皇把意大利抛在身后，搬到了阿维尼翁。而阿维尼翁已经变成了一个，嗯，他们称之为巴比伦囚虏，因为阿维尼翁似乎是一个拥有巨大财富和堕落的地方。所以那里有宏伟的花园和宴会厅，教皇甚至有自己的私人蒸汽浴室。因此人们有一种感觉，教皇不应该待在这种奢华的地方。他应该回到罗马。阿维尼翁的教皇宫，对于那些没去过的人来说，是一座绝对宏伟的建筑，我的意思是它是一座
terrifically imposing and impressive building isn't it but that's kind of the problem yeah but that's the problem because the pope is meant to be living in the heart and sort of talking to god instead of fine wines and tapestries he's supposed to be living in rome which is the the you know the seat of saint. Peter. Okay. So Tom, that's the Pope. He's off there in Avignon. But what about Siena? I mean, Siena, famously, this most exquisite of cities and a republic, I think? Yeah. So at this time, it's a republic. So Italy is fragmented into kind of tiny city-states, a bit like ancient Greece. Siena, its territory borders Florence, which
非常宏伟壮观的建筑，不是吗？但这就是问题所在。是的，但这就是问题所在，因为教皇本应生活在核心地带，与上帝对话，而不是沉溺于美酒和挂毯。他本应生活在罗马，也就是圣彼得的所在地。好吧。那么汤姆，那是教皇。他在阿维尼翁。但锡耶纳呢？我的意思是，锡耶纳，众所周知，这座最精致的城市，而且是一个共和国，我想？是的。所以在这个时候，它是一个共和国。所以意大利被分裂成一个个小城邦，有点像古希腊。锡耶纳的领土与佛罗伦萨接壤，而佛罗伦萨
is its great rival. But Siena is rich and sophisticated enough that it can go toe-to-toe with Florence in its golden age. So Siena really is enjoying a golden age at this time as well. It gets its wealth from wool, from manufacturing of clothes, but above all from banking. So it's one of the engine rooms of the starting of capitalism in Europe. The wealth that accrues from this enables it to adorn itself with absolutely splendid buildings, great towers, nobility buying great plazos everywhere. There there's an enormous Palazzo Pubblico. So this is the headquarters for the Republic. And the great patron of Siena is the Virgin Mary.
是它最大的竞争对手。但锡耶纳足够富有和先进，以至于在它的黄金时代可以与佛罗伦萨分庭抗礼。所以锡耶纳在这个时候也确实享受着黄金时代。它的财富来自羊毛、服装制造业，但最重要的是来自银行业。所以它是欧洲资本主义萌芽的引擎之一。由此积累的财富使它能够用绝对宏伟的建筑、高塔来装饰自己，贵族们到处购买宏伟的宫殿。那里有一个巨大的市政厅。所以这是共和国的总部。而锡耶纳伟大的守护神是圣母玛利亚。
So in the Palazzo Pubblico, in the very room where the government does its business, there's a kind of great painting of the Virgin with the Christ child. And then beyond it, you have the Campo, the kind of open, open square. Um,
所以在市政厅里，就在政府办公的房间里，有一幅巨大的圣母与圣婴的画作。而在它之外，你有坎波广场，那种开放的广场。嗯，
and, it, it said to emulate the, the kind of the outline of the cloak of the Virgin. Oh, nice. I did not know that. Yeah, that's very good.
据说它模仿了圣母斗篷的轮廓。哦，不错。我不知道这一点。是的，那非常好。
Yeah, that's very nice. So it's a very wealthy, very devout city. And perhaps the ultimate symbol of this is the building project that the city fathers have embarked on a few years before Catherine is born in 1347, which is to basically double the size of the city's cathedral. So work on that begins in 1339. And as Catherine is being born, the city is heaving with builders embarking on this great project of renewing and expanding
是的，那非常好。所以这是一座非常富有、非常虔诚的城市。而这最终的象征或许就是城市元老们在凯瑟琳1347年出生前几年开始的建筑项目，也就是基本上将城市大教堂的规模扩大一倍。所以工程始于1339年。就在凯瑟琳出生时，城市里挤满了建筑工人，他们正在进行这项更新和扩建大教堂的伟大工程。
the cathedral however dominic yeah i know you love a gathering storm cloud i did see that in your notes and i thought the amount of grief you give me about gathering about storm clouds like storm of war or whatever and and then well i thought you'd enjoy it because i knew you were a bit hesitant about this subject so i just wanted to make you feel at home. I absolutely do feel at home. So there are gathering storm clouds, Dominic. So am I feel at home already? Because I've actually been to Siena Cathedral in Assassin's Creed.
然而，多米尼克，是的，我知道你喜欢聚集的乌云。我确实在你的笔记里看到了，我当时想，你因为“聚集的乌云”——比如战争风暴之类的——而给我的那些抱怨，然后，嗯，我以为你会喜欢的，因为我知道你对这个主题有点犹豫，所以我只是想让你感到宾至如归。我确实感到宾至如归。所以有聚集的乌云，多米尼克。所以我已经感到宾至如归了吗？因为我实际上在《刺客信条》里去过锡耶纳大教堂。
So we'll find. Yeah, I'm laughing. It was brilliant. Is it being built? I think you're fighting the Borgias there, actually. Okay. A subject that we will return to in the rest of history. Yes, we will be. Okay.
那我们走着瞧。是的，我在笑。那太棒了。它正在建造中吗？我想你实际上是在那里对抗博尔吉亚家族。好吧。一个我们将在《历史余温》中回归的主题。是的，我们会回来的。好吧。
So as Catherine is being born, to repeat, the storm clouds are gathering. So again, listeners to our episodes on 100 Years' War may remember that Edward III has borrowed enormous amounts of money from Italian bankers to fund his war effort. And he defaults in 1345. And there's a kind of massive financial crash that particularly hits Florence, but the ripple effect of that hits Siena as well. So people are kind of going bust. There are a military reverses. So Siena loses a battle against Florence. And then in 1348,
所以正如凯瑟琳出生时所说，重复一遍，乌云正在聚集。所以，我们关于百年战争剧集的听众可能还记得，爱德华三世为了资助他的战争努力，从意大利银行家那里借了巨额资金。他在1345年违约了。发生了一场大规模的金融崩溃，特别打击了佛罗伦萨，但其连锁反应也波及了锡耶纳。所以人们基本上破产了。军事上遭遇了挫折。所以锡耶纳输掉了一场对佛罗伦萨的战斗。然后在1348年，
so a year after Catherine has been born, the biggest disaster of all hits Siena, which is, of course, the Black Death. Yeah. So that arrives in Siena in May 1348, which is a month after it's hit Florence. And the Sienese are aware it's coming. They try and impose a very strict quarantine, kind of Jacinda Ardern style attempt to preserve the people of sienna from infection but it doesn't work the black death comes in people start dropping ill shops close up the courts close down the wool industry you know goes into deep freeze plague pits are dug everywhere and there's a contemporary chronicler who says you know he describes people kind of walking around
也就是凯瑟琳出生一年后，最大的灾难降临到了锡耶纳，那当然就是黑死病。是的。所以它在1348年5月到达锡耶纳，比它袭击佛罗伦萨晚了一个月。锡耶纳人意识到它要来了。他们试图实施非常严格的隔离，类似于杰辛达·阿德恩式的尝试，试图保护锡耶纳人民免受感染，但没有奏效。黑死病来了，人们开始病倒，商店关闭，法院关闭，羊毛工业陷入深度冻结，到处都在挖掘瘟疫坑。有一位当代编年史家说，你知道，他描述人们走来走去，
and then just dropping dead with the distinctive swellings under the arms and in the groin. They fell dead while talking. And there is a kind of enduring monument to the scale of the crisis, of the impact of the Black Death on Siena, which is that they abandoned the building of the cathedral. So to this day, it remains unbuilt. But also there's a sense, isn't there, of sort of public, well, religiosity reaching a peak because people are begging God for help and they are flagellating themselves for their sins, or I mean, not flagellating themselves, but aren't they doing processions and preachers withering on about God is judging you and all this stuff? Yes.
然后就倒地身亡，腋下和腹股沟有明显的肿胀。他们边说话边倒地身亡。而且有一个持久的纪念碑，见证了黑死病对锡耶纳影响的规模，那就是他们放弃了大教堂的建设。所以直到今天，它仍然没有建成。但也有某种感觉，不是吗？某种公共的，嗯，宗教热情达到了顶峰，因为人们在祈求上帝的帮助，他们为了自己的罪孽而鞭笞自己，或者我的意思是，不是鞭笞自己，但他们不是在进行游行吗？还有传教士在喋喋不休地说上帝在审判你们，所有这些东西？是的。
So it absolutely turbo charges a sense that god is angry god has to be appeased people need to look into their souls so this is the world that katherine is born into and she loses several of her brothers and sisters to the black death and also it impacts her father because he is a dyer so um you know the the kind of clothing industry the wool trade is very important to him and so that gets hit by the black death but he i mean he is well off he the kind of clothing industry the wool trade is very important to him and so that gets hit by the black death but he i mean he is well off he's a kind of upwardly mobile guy and he he rides out the the impact of the black death and his business survives it so catherine is born into this kind of upwardly mobile family and her mother um lapper according according to Raymond of Capua, who is Catherine of Siena's biographer and also her kind of spiritual advisor, writes up her life after her death.
所以这绝对加速了一种感觉，即上帝很愤怒，上帝必须被安抚，人们需要审视自己的灵魂。所以这就是凯瑟琳出生的世界，她失去了几个兄弟姐妹死于黑死病，这也影响了她的父亲，因为他是一名染匠，所以，嗯，你知道，服装工业、羊毛贸易对他来说非常重要，所以这受到了黑死病的打击。但他，我的意思是，他很富有，他是一个积极进取的人，他度过了黑死病的冲击，他的生意幸存了下来。所以凯瑟琳出生在一个积极进取的家庭，她的母亲拉帕，根据雷蒙德·德·卡普阿的说法，他是锡耶纳凯瑟琳的传记作者，也是她的精神导师，在凯瑟琳死后写下了她的生平。
He describes Lapa filling the house with children like a fruitful bee. That's a nice image. Yeah. And she seems to have had 25 children in all. Not all of them survive, as we'll find out. Yeah. and all um not all of them survive as we'll find out 25 yeah and she has katherine and a twin sister when she's kind of in her early 40s and um they're born prematurely lapper breastfeeds katherine herself and actually she's the only the only one of her daughters who she breastfeeds
他描述拉帕像一只多产的蜜蜂一样让家里充满了孩子。那是个不错的形象。是的。她似乎总共生了25个孩子。并非所有人都活了下来，我们稍后会发现。是的。而且并非所有人都活了下来，我们稍后会发现，25个，是的。她在40岁出头时生下了凯瑟琳和一个双胞胎妹妹，她们是早产儿。拉帕亲自给凯瑟琳哺乳，实际上她是她唯一亲自哺乳的女儿。
and katherine seems to have been her favorite and the other the other twin sister Giovanna is sent out to a wet nurse and she dies shortly afterwards and then after Catherine um and and Giovanna have been born a last daughter is born to um to Lapa and her husband and she is given Giovanna's name so So for Catherine growing up, there is a kind of reminder of the absence of her twin in this younger sister. That was not uncommon, Tom, I think, was it? I mean, but that was quite common that if a child died, you would reuse the name later on. Yeah. But kind of interesting just to think what the impact of that might have been on Catherine. Yeah.
凯瑟琳似乎是她的最爱，而另一个双胞胎妹妹乔瓦娜被送去给奶妈喂养，不久后就去世了。然后在凯瑟琳和乔瓦娜出生后，拉帕和她的丈夫又生了一个小女儿，她被取名为乔瓦娜。所以对于凯瑟琳的成长来说，这个小妹妹身上有一种提醒她双胞胎妹妹缺席的感觉。汤姆，我想那并不罕见，对吧？我的意思是，如果一个孩子去世了，后来再用这个名字，这很常见。是的。但想到这对凯瑟琳可能产生的影响，还是挺有趣的。是的。
Anyway, so she is actually a very happy child. She's kind of given the nickname in Greek of Mary. She's kind of running around the house, able to run out into the streets, have fun. Chuckling. Chuckling, all that kind of famous five activity, out with her brothers, all this kind of thing. Unmasking smugglers. Yes. And she has an elder sister to whom she's very devoted called Bonaventura.
总之，她实际上是一个非常快乐的孩子。她被赋予了希腊语名字玛丽的昵称。她在家里跑来跑去，能跑到街上玩耍。咯咯笑。咯咯笑，所有那些著名的五人组活动，和她的兄弟们在一起，所有这些事情。揭露走私者。是的。她有一个非常敬爱的姐姐，叫博纳文图拉。
And Bonaventura is married off, as of course it's expected Catherine will be. And her husband is a bit of a lad, a bit of a rake, very kind of loose and dissipated. And Bonaventura doesn't approve of this. And so she basically shames him into reforming his life by going on a kind of hunger strike. Crikey. Yeah. And so this works. But Bonaventura is very into her clothes. She loves her fashion. And she gets Catherine very interested in fashion. So Catherine's kind of 14, 15 by this point, starting to get interested in clothes. And Raymond of Capua, her biographer,
博纳文图拉被嫁了出去，当然人们也期望凯瑟琳会这样。她的丈夫是个花花公子，有点放荡，非常散漫。博纳文图拉不赞成这一点。所以她基本上通过绝食羞辱他，让他改过自新。天哪。是的。这奏效了。但博纳文图拉非常喜欢她的衣服。她热爱时尚。她让凯瑟琳对时尚产生了浓厚的兴趣。所以凯瑟琳当时大约14、15岁，开始对衣服感兴趣。而她的传记作者雷蒙德·德·卡普阿，
does not approve of this at all and he describes of of the way that bonaventura has been getting catherine into um fashion almighty god unable to bear the sight of his chosen bride being drawn even the slightest bit further away from him himself removed the obstacle that was preventing her from uniting herself with him for bonaventura having led her holy sister into the ways of vanity, shortly afterwards found herself about to give birth, and young as she was, died in doing so. Right. If she's been Catherine's big sister, in every sense, kind of introducing her, they're much loved, then that could be a bit of a psychological blow for, well, a big psychological
一点也不赞成这一点，他描述了博纳文图拉让凯瑟琳接触时尚的方式。全能的上帝，无法忍受看到他选定的新娘被哪怕一点点地从他身边拉开，移除了阻碍她与他结合的障碍。因为博纳文图拉在引导她神圣的妹妹走上虚荣之路后，不久就发现自己要分娩了，尽管她还很年轻，却在分娩中去世了。对。如果她是凯瑟琳的姐姐，在各方面都是，引导她，她们非常相爱，那么这对凯瑟琳来说可能是一个心理打击，嗯，一个巨大的心理
blow for Catherine. Yes. And all the more so because her parents want her to marry Bonaventura's widower, the reformed lad. And she doesn't fancy that. She does not fancy that at all. And that is basically because she has already decided that she is giving herself over to God because from a very young age, kind of five or six, she has been having visions of
打击。是的。更何况她的父母想让她嫁给博纳文图拉的鳏夫，那个改过自新的花花公子。她不喜欢那样。她一点也不喜欢那样。这基本上是因为她已经决定把自己献给上帝，因为从很小的时候，大约五六岁，她就开始看到基督的异象。
Christ. One day she's out with her brother, you know, solving crimes and foiling smugglers and all that kind of thing. And then suddenly she sees this vision of Christ absolutely thrown in a blaze of glory. And she's so startled that she looks away and then she looks back and it's gone and the vision has gone. But it gives her this kind of yearning to see Christ again and so she starts praying to christ she starts praying to the virgin she is particularly inspired by the great saints of egypt among whom is someone who has her name catherine catherine of alexandria um who is martyred by being tied to a wheel so as in as in the catherine wheel that you get in firework displays.
有一天她和她的兄弟出去，你知道，破案、阻止走私者之类的。然后突然她看到了基督在荣耀中显现的异象。她非常吃惊，以至于她移开了视线，然后她又看回去，它消失了，异象消失了。但这给了她一种再次见到基督的渴望，所以她开始向基督祈祷，她开始向圣母祈祷，她特别受到埃及伟大圣徒的启发，其中有一个和她同名的人，亚历山大的凯瑟琳，她被绑在轮子上殉道，就像你在烟花表演中看到的凯瑟琳轮一样。
And Catherine had a kind of mystical marriage to Christ. So this is obviously something that's playing on the mind of the young Catherine of Siena, this idea that a Catherine, if you are sufficiently saintly, you can end up marrying Christ himself. And so she starts to embark on increasingly kind of ascetic behavior. She starts to starve herself. She starts to scourge herself. She basically starts to kind of mortify the flesh. And this is in her mid-teens, Tom. So this is in her mid-teens. So even as she is kind of being tempted by Bonaventura to try on kind of dresses. She's also, you know, being tempted to go the other way. That kind of saintly direction is then massively amplified by the pressure she gets from her parents to marry Bonaventura's widower.
凯瑟琳与基督有一种神秘的婚姻。所以这显然是锡耶纳年轻的凯瑟琳脑海中挥之不去的事情，这种想法是，如果你足够圣洁，你最终可以嫁给基督本人。所以她开始进行越来越苦行的行为。她开始挨饿。她开始鞭笞自己。她基本上开始折磨肉体。汤姆，这还是在她十几岁的时候。所以这还是在她十几岁的时候。所以即使她被博纳文图拉诱惑去试穿各种裙子，她也同时被诱惑去走另一条路。那种圣洁的方向随后被她父母强迫她嫁给博纳文图拉的鳏夫的压力大大放大了。
Yes. Because basically she's hitting puberty and she's being pressured by her parents to, you know, titillate herself and to attract men. And she's suddenly, she's not being allowed to go and roam the streets anymore. She's only allowed out with a chaperone and she hates it. And so she commits herself very, very radically to virginity. And the devil, Raymond of Capua says, kind of tempts her by bringing her vile pictures of men and women behaving loosely before her mind and foul figures before her eyes and obscene words to her ears,
是的。因为基本上她正处于青春期，她的父母在向她施压，让她，你知道，取悦自己并吸引男人。她突然不再被允许在街上游荡了。她只被允许在有监护人的情况下出门，她讨厌这样。所以她非常、非常激进地致力于保持贞洁。雷蒙德·德·卡普阿说，魔鬼通过在她脑海中呈现男人和女人行为放荡的卑劣画面，在她眼前呈现污秽的形象，在她耳边呈现淫秽的词语来诱惑她，
shameless crowds dancing around her, howling and sniggering and inviting her to join them. But Dominic, she never does. So there's an awful lot going on here, Tom. And I think to a 21st century reader, what's going on seems fairly obvious, doesn't it? Well, I think we'll come to what might be going on a bit later on, but just to continue the description of what is happening in Catherine's life. And, you know, the fact that she is not only kind of committing herself to virginity, but she is also trying to suppress basically her femininity. So she cuts her hair off very short. She tries to make herself look ugly. She
无耻的人群在她周围跳舞，嚎叫、窃笑并邀请她加入他们。但多米尼克，她从来没有加入。所以这里发生了很多事情，汤姆。我认为对于21世纪的读者来说，发生的事情似乎相当明显，不是吗？嗯，我想我们稍后会谈到可能发生的事情，但只是继续描述凯瑟琳生活中正在发生的事情。而且，你知道，她不仅致力于保持贞洁，她还试图基本上压制她的女性气质。所以她把头发剪得很短。她试图让自己看起来很丑。她
starves herself. I mean, very, very severely. She starts to wear a chain around her waist. Her parents are very anxious about this. I mean, they're kind of worried about her. Her mother takes her off to a spa with hot springs to see if this might help her out. And she deliberately schools herself in the hot springs. And she basically, she refuses to go to sleep as well. And she stays up all night kind of doing the work of a servant, doing the laundry, doing the housework. And when her mother forces her to come to bed, to share a bed with her mother so that she can't get up, she secretes a plank underneath the mattress or she'll kind of creep out of bed to lie on the floor.
挨饿。我的意思是，非常、非常严重。她开始在腰间戴上一条铁链。她的父母对此非常焦虑。我的意思是，他们很担心她。她的母亲带她去了一个有温泉的疗养地，看看这是否能帮到她。她故意在温泉里折磨自己。她基本上，她也拒绝睡觉。她整夜不睡，做仆人的工作，洗衣服，做家务。当她的母亲强迫她上床，和她母亲同床以便她不能起床时，她在床垫下藏了一块木板，或者她会偷偷溜下床躺在地板上。
So basically, this is overtly a rebellion against her parents, against what her parents want for her. Because her parents want for her what most parents in this period want for their daughter. They want them to marry them off. They want them to kind of become wives and mothers. It's very clear that this is very overtly what catherine is rebelling against and catherine feels that in kind of embarking on this she is not alone because christ is with her so now christ is appearing to her a lot he's visiting her in her own room and she's not being made to sleep with her mother yeah you know she has her own room and he is appearing to her nailed on the cross with all the markers of the torture inflicted on him so there's a lot of blood and he starts
所以基本上，这公开是对她父母的反叛，反对她父母对她的期望。因为她的父母希望她像这一时期大多数父母希望他们的女儿那样。他们想把她们嫁出去。他们想让她们成为妻子和母亲。很明显，这非常公开地是凯瑟琳所反叛的东西。凯瑟琳觉得在开始这一切时，她并不孤单，因为基督与她同在。所以现在基督经常向她显现，他在她自己的房间里拜访她，她不再被迫和她母亲一起睡觉。是的，你知道，她有自己的房间，他向她显现，被钉在十字架上，身上带着所有施加在他身上的酷刑的痕迹，所以有很多血，他开始
talking to her in increasingly intimate terms and raymond has this very kind of sweet description of of the conversation between um catherine and and christ generally he came and talked to catherine as one friend to another so much so she shyly confessed to me that is that is raymond that they would say the psalms together walking up and down the little room like two religious brothers saying their offices so very sweet one quick question is he still on the cross he's walking up and down don't know dominic but that's the question i would put to raymond at this point that's such a protestant question he's kind of hopping up and down no i imagine he comes down from the cross but I don't know, Dominic. That's the question I would put to Raymond at this point. That's such a Protestant question.
用越来越亲密的词语和她交谈，雷蒙德对凯瑟琳和基督之间的对话有一个非常甜蜜的描述。通常他来和凯瑟琳交谈，就像朋友对朋友一样。以至于她羞涩地向我承认，那就是雷蒙德，他们会一起念诗篇，在小房间里走来走去，就像两个宗教兄弟在做他们的祈祷一样。非常甜蜜。一个快速的问题，他还在十字架上吗？他在走来走去。不知道，多米尼克，但那是我此时会向雷蒙德提出的问题。那真是个新教的问题。他在那里蹦蹦跳跳。不，我想象他从十字架上下来了，但我不知道，多米尼克。那是我此时会向雷蒙德提出的问题。那真是个新教的问题。
He's kind of hopping up and down. No, I imagine he comes down from the cross, but I imagine he's still bleeding, would be my suggestion. Well, I'm sure that definitely happened. So he's leaving blood all over the floor, which Catherine's written. She loves that. Right. And the result of this is a miracle. The previously illiterate Catherine is able to read.
他在那里蹦蹦跳跳。不，我想象他从十字架上下来了，但我猜他还在流血。嗯，我相信那肯定发生了。所以他在地板上留下了血，凯瑟琳写过。她喜欢那样。对。而这一切的结果是一个奇迹。以前文盲的凯瑟琳能够阅读了。
Crikey. That is an unexpected boon. And she becomes very, very scholarly. So her writings are what ultimately in the long run will make her one of the doctors of the church. And she hadn't been taught to read at all. And the ultimate fruit of this is that she ends up marrying Jesus. So David, who writes the psalms he
天哪。那是一个意想不到的收获。她变得非常有学问。所以她的著作最终在长期来看将使她成为教会的圣师之一。而她根本没有受过阅读教育。而这一切的最终成果是她最终嫁给了耶稣。所以大卫，写诗篇的那个人，他
plays the harp oh he's there now he's there too yeah we'll add the wedding so he comes is this still in her room this is all in her room yeah okay i mean raymond caprio said it was a little room so it must be getting pretty crowded in there but it's miraculous dominic you're entering the dimension of the supernatural oh yeah okay so saint paul is a witness. Mary, the Virgin Mary, leads her up to Christ. And Christ, you know, takes her by his hand and gives her his foreskin and puts it on her finger. Yeah. And they are married. It sounds such a lovely, what a lovely day.
弹竖琴。哦，他现在也在那里。是的，我们加上婚礼。所以他来了。这还在她的房间里吗？这都在她的房间里。是的。好吧，我的意思是雷蒙德·德·卡普阿说那是一个小房间，所以那里一定变得非常拥挤，但这是奇迹，多米尼克。你正在进入超自然的维度。哦，是的，好吧，所以圣保罗是见证人。玛丽，圣母玛利亚，领她到基督面前。而基督，你知道，牵着她的手，把他的包皮给了她，戴在她的手指上。是的。他们结婚了。听起来真是美好的一天。
Yeah. Yeah. And then Christ orders her to go out into the world and to manifest to her family, to the people of Siena, and in the long run to the world, this kind of awesome power that she has been endowed with. And it becomes evident to her parents that they are not going to get her to marry. So basically, they accept her vocation. And she joins the Dominicans, this order that had been set up by your name, St. Dominic, originally to combat the Albigensians. But she doesn't join them as a nun. She's a kind of lay sister. And she commits herself utterly to the service of the poor, which is quite annoying for her parents because every time they have any money or food in the house, she kind of takes it and gives it out to the starving or the sick. Right. So Tom, a question that you will probably think a Protestant question. So this is not a money-making scheme by her parents, quite the reverse. They're losing
是的。是的。然后基督命令她走向世界，向她的家人、向锡耶纳人民，并从长远来看向世界，展示她所被赋予的这种令人敬畏的力量。她的父母很明显意识到他们无法让她结婚。所以基本上，他们接受了她的天职。她加入了多明我会，这个由你的名字圣多米尼克创立的教团，最初是为了对抗阿尔比派。但她并不是以修女的身份加入的。她是一种平信徒姐妹。她完全致力于服务穷人，这让她的父母很烦恼，因为每次家里有钱或食物，她就会拿去分给饥饿或生病的人。对。所以汤姆，一个你可能会认为是新教的问题。所以这不是她父母的赚钱计划，恰恰相反。他们正在失去
money rather than gaining it. Completely. They're completely losing her money. At one point, her father has brought in some really top quality wine. Catherine immediately takes it and kind of hands it out to beggars. And, uh, her father is furious about this. And then miraculously, um, you know, the cask starts flowing with, with wonderful wine and everyone can come in and share it. So maybe, I mean, who knows, but, but definitely people think that miracles are happening and that the displays of charity are you know spectacular and she goes out there and she performs miracles she she heals the sick she a particular trick of hers is to restore um milk to the breasts of women who um whose breasts have gone dry she makes
钱而不是获得钱。完全是。他们完全在失去她的钱。有一次，她父亲带回了一些顶级品质的葡萄酒。凯瑟琳立即拿走并分给了乞丐。而且，嗯，她父亲对此非常愤怒。然后奇迹般地，嗯，你知道，酒桶开始流出美妙的葡萄酒，每个人都可以进来分享。所以也许，我的意思是，谁知道呢，但肯定人们认为奇迹正在发生，而且这些慈善展示是，你知道，壮观的。她走出去，她创造奇迹，她治愈病人，她有一个特别的绝活，就是为那些乳汁干涸的妇女恢复乳汁，她用腐烂的小麦做
bread from rotten wheat and these loaves then multiply rather as the miracles that Christ himself had done. And on one occasion, her mother seems to die and Catherine complains to God and her mother comes back to life. So that's all very spectacular. And then when Lapper dies, Christ himself gives her Mary Magdalene to be her mother mother so that's nice okay but the greatest miracle of all that she performs and which is very very obvious and very spectacular is her fasting she really really starts to um not eat anything at all pretty much and it's this that really really starts to get get attention because it's kind of a spectacular display of asceticism and self-abnegation. And she started to exercise power within her own house, her parents increasingly
面包，这些面包然后成倍增加，就像基督自己所做的奇迹一样。有一次，她的母亲似乎去世了，凯瑟琳向上帝抱怨，她的母亲又活了过来。所以这一切都非常壮观。然后当拉帕去世时，基督本人给了她抹大拉的玛丽作为她的母亲。所以那很好。好吧，但她所创造的最伟大的奇迹，也是非常、非常明显和壮观的，是她的禁食。她真的、真的开始，嗯，几乎什么都不吃。正是这一点真正开始引起注意，因为它是一种壮观的苦行和自我克制的展示。她开始在自己的家里行使权力，她的父母越来越
in awe of her. But her holiness becomes something that people in Siena start to be very proud of and very respectful of. And they start to hail her as a donna, a free woman. So this is supposedly an illiterate daughter of a dyer. And increasingly, she is becoming, as she describes herself, the owner and mistress of herself. And she sees herself as being the pilot of a great ship on the tempestuous sea that is this life of shadows. And this gives her power. So in 1371, there are great riots throughout Siena and Catherine walks through the riots and brings peace to the streets. 1374, plague returns to Siena. Catherine again does spectacular and miraculous healings throughout this outbreak of the plague. And in 1375, she goes to Pisa, which is when she writes to that
敬畏她。但她的圣洁成为锡耶纳人民开始感到非常自豪和尊重的东西。他们开始称她为“唐娜”，一个自由的女人。所以这据称是一个染匠的文盲女儿。而且她越来越成为她自己所描述的，她自己的主人和女主人。她把自己看作是这充满阴影的生活这波涛汹涌的大海上一艘大船的舵手。这给了她力量。所以1371年，锡耶纳各地发生了大骚乱，凯瑟琳走过骚乱，给街道带来了和平。1374年，瘟疫回到锡耶纳。凯瑟琳再次在这次瘟疫爆发期间进行了壮观和奇迹般的治愈。1375年，她去了比萨，那时她写信给那位
nun that we opened the episode with. And there she persuades the people of Pisa and the people of the neighboring city of Lucca to abandon a league against the Pope and to sign up to the authority of the Pope. So she's starting to become a figure within the politics of Italy. And it's at this time that she starts writing to the Pope himself, Gregory XI, who is off in Avignon, exhorting him to return to Rome. And Gregory XI, he takes her letters, he replies to them, and he comments about her letters that they have an intolerably dictatorial tone, a little sweetened with expressions of her perfect Christian deference, which is obviously very, very kind of Catherine. And then the following year in 1376, she actually goes to Avignon. She's been sent by Florence, you know, so an amazing tribute to a woman from the Florentines' great enemy of Siena. Catherine goes to Avignon as their ambassador. And even though once she has
我们在剧集开头提到的修女。在那里，她说服了比萨人民和邻近城市卢卡的人民放弃反对教皇的联盟，并签署承认教皇的权威。所以她开始成为意大利政治中的一个人物。就在这个时候，她开始写信给教皇本人，格列高利十一世，他当时在阿维尼翁，劝告他回到罗马。而格列高利十一世，他收到了她的信，他回复了它们，并评论说她的信有一种令人无法忍受的独裁语气，稍微用她完美的基督教谦卑的表达方式进行了修饰，这显然非常、非常凯瑟琳。然后第二年，1376年，她实际上去了阿维尼翁。她是受佛罗伦萨派遣的，你知道，所以这对佛罗伦萨人来说是对锡耶纳伟大敌人的女性的惊人致敬。凯瑟琳作为他们的大使去了阿维尼翁。即使一旦她
kind of smoothed things for the Florentines, the Florentines dismiss her as an ambassador, she has met the Pope and the Pope is incredibly, incredibly taken with her. He finds her amazingly impressive. And sure enough, in January 1377, the miraculous happens. He leaves Avignon for Rome. It seems as though the Babylonian exile of the papacy is over, and people absolutely feel that it is Catherine who has affected this. So you can say of Catherine that she is seen by people in a tormented world to be a living symbol of sanctity, a living symbol of the fact that God can animate the dimension of the human and that this sanctity is having a measurable impact on the geopolitics of the age.
为佛罗伦萨人平息了事情，佛罗伦萨人解雇了她作为大使，她已经见到了教皇，而教皇对她印象非常、非常深刻。他发现她令人惊叹地令人印象深刻。果然，1377年1月，奇迹发生了。他离开阿维尼翁前往罗马。似乎教皇的巴比伦流亡结束了，人们绝对感觉到是凯瑟琳促成了这一点。所以你可以说凯瑟琳被一个受折磨的世界中的人们视为圣洁的活象征，视为上帝可以激活人类维度这一事实的活象征，并且这种圣洁正在对那个时代的地缘政治产生可衡量的影响。
So, I mean, that is, I think, amazing. And you may well wonder, well, two things, I guess. How is she able to leverage this? And what is going on in her mind what is all this stuff all right blood and things tom let us end on this thrilling cliffhanger or rather let's take a break on this thrilling cliffhanger we'll be back in just a few minutes and you can explain the answers to these exciting questions see you in a second i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment in a second. Welcome back to The Rest Is History.
所以，我的意思是，我认为这很了不起。你可能很想知道，嗯，我想是两件事。她是如何利用这一点的？她的脑子里在想什么？所有这些东西，好吧，血之类的，汤姆，让我们在这个激动人心的悬念中结束，或者更确切地说，让我们在这个激动人心的悬念中休息一下，几分钟后我们就会回来，你可以解释这些令人兴奋的问题的答案。一会儿见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐余温》，一会儿见。欢迎回到《历史余温》。
We're talking about Catherine of Siena. For Tom Holland, one of the two most important women in all history. And Tom, what is going on there? So there are obvious explanations, I would say. I mean, even without looking at your notes where you've written down the various possibilities, I would have said the obvious explanations are, number one, this really happened.
我们正在谈论锡耶纳的凯瑟琳。对于汤姆·霍兰德来说，她是历史上最重要的两位女性之一。汤姆，那里发生了什么？所以，我会说有明显的解释。我的意思是，即使不看你写下各种可能性的笔记，我也会说明显的解释是，第一，这真的发生了。
All these people did cram into her bedroom for this extraordinary wedding ceremony. Yeah, well, sure. There was loads of blood, all that. That's all real. That is what Catholics believe. Right. And number two is, she is a deeply troubled teenager there's been all the
所有这些人确实挤进了她的卧室参加这场非凡的婚礼。是的，当然。有很多血，所有这些。那都是真实的。这就是天主教徒所相信的。对。第二是，她是一个深受困扰的青少年，发生了所有
stuff with her dead twin with her dead sister with the pressure from her parents to get married she is going through a whole series of kind of mental health issues that are very familiar to us in the 21st century and she's living through a time of enormous political fragmentation, anxiety about the Black Death, all of these things, and that the people of Siena and beyond are projecting onto her, they're making of her what they need, which is a saintly figure who will give them a sense of salvation, unity, whatever. The Pope was probably going to go to Rome anyway. So steer us through it.
关于她死去的双胞胎、她死去的姐姐、她父母强迫她结婚的事情，她正在经历一系列我们21世纪非常熟悉的心理健康问题，她生活在一个政治分裂、对黑死病感到焦虑的时代，所有这些事情，锡耶纳及其他地方的人们正在把他们自己投射到她身上，他们把她塑造成他们所需要的人，即一个会给他们带来救赎感、统一感等的圣洁人物。教皇可能无论如何都会去罗马。所以引导我们了解一下。
I have no knowledge of this at all, so I'm just guessing. No, you're right. There are two obvious explanations. One is that it's all true, it all happened, that's why she's a saint. And the other is exactly that you look back and you medicalize it and you read through the accounts that are written of her, look at her own letters, look at the life written of her by her confessor, Raymond of Capua. And all these kind of details, as you said, you highlighted the fact that she probably feels and perhaps a measure of guilt that she has lived and her twin sister has died um and her twin sister has died because she didn't have the milk oh yeah of course mother's milk and she did yeah so maybe there's something going on there the thing of her favorite sister starving herself to persuade her husband to behave
我对此一无所知，所以我只是在猜测。不，你是对的。有两个明显的解释。一个是这一切都是真的，这一切都发生了，这就是她成为圣徒的原因。另一个正是你回顾过去并将其医学化，阅读关于她的记录，看看她自己的信件，看看她的忏悔者雷蒙德·德·卡普阿为她写的生平。所有这些细节，正如你所说，你强调了她可能感到，也许是一种内疚感，因为她活了下来而她的双胞胎妹妹去世了，嗯，她的双胞胎妹妹去世了，因为她没有母乳，哦，是的，当然是母乳，而她有，是的，所以也许那里发生了一些事情。她最喜欢的姐姐为了说服丈夫表现好而绝食的事情。
and then dying in childbirth. That again, this is the kind of thing that you, a psychologist would probably say that that might encourage her to feel that food can be used as a kind of, as a tool, as a weapon, and also to feel that marriage and childbirth is something dangerous and threatening. Yeah. To give her a dread of sex, presumably. Yeah, but also a dread of food. So I'm not a psychologist at all, and I talk with some hesitation about this. I mean, I've read scholars who have written about this, so I will say what they say, which is that it's fairly clear that the modern diagnosis of Catherine would be that she is suffering from anorexia she is progressively starving herself um so from the age of 16 so exactly the age when her parents are starting
然后死于难产。这又回到了那个问题，作为一个心理学家，你可能会说，这可能会促使她觉得食物可以被用作一种工具、一种武器，同时也让她觉得婚姻和分娩是危险且具有威胁性的。是的。大概是让她对性产生恐惧。是的，但同时也对食物产生恐惧。我完全不是心理学家，谈论这个时有些犹豫。我的意思是，我读过学者们关于此的论述，所以我将转述他们的观点，即现代对凯瑟琳的诊断很明确，她患有厌食症，她正在逐渐让自己挨饿，嗯，从16岁开始，也就是她父母开始
to pressure her to to marry she is eating nothing except uh bread raw vegetables all she's drinking is is uh water and then from her early 20s it becomes really, really severe. So she's eating bitter herbs, which she will chew up and then often just spit out. She's having the Eucharist, so the wafer, the bread that is supposedly the body of Christ, and again, water. So I mean, this is very, very severe. And she's told by Christ herself, she says, after their marriage, that she has to go back to her parents' table and eat. And she tries to obey him, but she can't take food down. And so, again, there are reports that she will stick twigs down the back of her throat to make herself vomit, to throw up food. And so Raymond of Capua says specifically her stomach could no longer digest food.
向她施压要求她结婚的年纪，她除了面包和生蔬菜什么都不吃，只喝水，到了20岁出头，情况变得非常非常严重。她吃苦草，嚼碎后往往又吐掉。她领圣餐，也就是那块被认为是基督身体的薄饼，再加上水。所以我的意思是，这非常非常严重。她在婚后，她说基督亲自告诉她，她必须回到父母的餐桌上吃饭。她试图服从他，但她无法咽下食物。所以，同样有报道称，她会把树枝插进喉咙深处让自己呕吐，把食物吐出来。因此，卡普阿的雷蒙德明确表示，她的胃已经无法消化食物了。
He says it's a medical condition. And so the question then is, is there a way of negotiating these two extremes? Because one is very much bred of the 14th century. It's bred of an age where it is absolutely assumed that Christ could appear to those who are particularly saintly. And our age is much more sceptical. It's much more secular. It's much more prone to kind of medicalize everything. Is there a way of kind of walking that tightrope of perhaps of squaring those circles? And there is one book in particular, which I highly commend to anyone who's interested, not just in Catherine, but in, I mean, basically the whole field of the mindset of the Middle Ages.
他说这是一种医疗状况。那么问题就在于，有没有办法协调这两个极端？因为其中一个非常带有14世纪的色彩。它诞生于一个绝对认为基督可以向特别圣洁的人显现的时代。而我们这个时代更加怀疑，更加世俗，也更容易把一切事物医疗化。有没有一种方法可以走那根钢丝，或许能把这些矛盾统一起来？有一本书我特别向所有感兴趣的人推荐，不仅是对凯瑟琳感兴趣，而且是对中世纪心态的整个领域感兴趣的人。
And it's a book by a great scholar called Caroline Walker Bynum, Holy Feast and Holy Fast, the Religious Significance of Food to Medieval Women. And it is really superb. It's not just about Catherine, but Catherine kind of is at the heart of the analysis. And it's brilliant at looking how there are things about Catherine that are very, very culturally specific. It's bred of things that are very, very specific to the age. And that therefore, to say, well, she was anorexic is very reductive. Indeed, almost anachronistic. Because that's not to deny that she probably was anorexic, but it's also to recognize that there were people in the Middle Ages who understood,
这是一本由伟大的学者卡罗琳·沃克·拜纳姆所著的书，《圣宴与圣斋：食物对中世纪女性的宗教意义》。它真的很棒。它不仅仅是关于凯瑟琳的，但凯瑟琳处于分析的核心。它非常出色地审视了凯瑟琳身上那些具有非常、非常强烈的文化特殊性的东西。它源于那个时代非常、非常具体的事物。因此，说她患有厌食症是非常片面的。事实上，几乎是时代错误。因为这并不是要否认她可能确实患有厌食症，而是要认识到中世纪确实有人理解，
they had a sense of eating disorders. They recognized that there were people who, and particularly girls, who might starve themselves out of opposition to their parents or because they were ill. I mean, they did understand that. Catherine's contemporaries did not think that this is what she was, even though Catherine herself recognized that there was an element of infirmity about it, that her inability to digest food was a kind of medical complaint. So just to say she's anorexic does not really get to grips with the complexity of what is going on here. So essentially, I said at the beginning that this is a time when there is increasing famine across Europe. Harvests are failing and it's a subsistence era. So food is a constant obsession for people.
他们对饮食失调有一种感知。他们认识到有些人，特别是女孩，可能会因为反对父母或因为生病而让自己挨饿。我的意思是，他们确实理解这一点。凯瑟琳的同时代人并不认为她就是这样，尽管凯瑟琳本人也认识到其中有一种虚弱的成分，即她无法消化食物是一种医疗上的病症。所以，仅仅说她患有厌食症并不能真正抓住这里所发生事情的复杂性。所以本质上，我在开头说过，这是一个欧洲各地饥荒日益严重的时期。收成歉收，这是一个维持生计的时代。所以食物是人们持续的痴迷。
The threat of starvation is omnipresent. And so there's a sense in the Middle Ages that almost the deadliest of the deadly sins is gluttony and that to renounce food is the kind of ultimate renunciation. And this is particularly true for women, because it is women in the medieval household who are charged with the provision of food, with the cooking of it, with the preparation of it, with the serving of it. And therefore, because of that, a woman who renounces food, her renunciation is much more visible, say, than that of a man. And it's evident that Catherine is, you know,
饥饿的威胁无处不在。因此，中世纪有一种观念，认为七宗罪中最致命的几乎就是贪食，而放弃食物是一种终极的放弃。这对女性来说尤其如此，因为在中世纪家庭中，负责提供食物、烹饪、准备和上菜的正是女性。因此，正因为如此，一个放弃食物的女性，她的放弃比男性要显眼得多。而且很明显，凯瑟琳，你知道，
it's not just that she's cutting off her hair and refusing to marry. By rejecting food, she is elevating herself as a woman above the normal rank of women. Oh, that's interesting. This is why she's becoming a donna, paradoxically. A free woman. She's elevating herself above her her social rank by doing that so if you're a gender theorist or something you could have a field day with all this right i mean yeah she is rebelling against her gender role it's not just that she's troubled by sexuality or whatever
不仅仅是剪掉头发和拒绝结婚。通过拒绝食物，她作为女性将自己提升到了普通女性的阶层之上。哦，这很有趣。这就是为什么她矛盾地成为了一名“自由女性”。通过这样做，她将自己提升到了社会阶层之上，所以如果你是一个性别理论家之类的，你可以在这一切中大做文章，对吧？我的意思是，是的，她在反抗她的性别角色，不仅仅是她被性或其他什么东西所困扰，
but she is actually actively resisting and subverting the role it's cutting her hair presumably dressing and well what's so fascinating? Having initially been obsessed with clothes and fashion, she then veers to the other extreme, rebels against it. She wears the habit of a Dominican. Right. Yeah, she's absolutely not kind of celebrating fashion. But there's a further dimension, Dominic,
而是她实际上在积极地抵制和颠覆这个角色。剪掉头发，大概还有穿着，嗯，最迷人的是什么？最初沉迷于衣服和时尚，然后她转向了另一个极端，反抗它。她穿上了多米尼克修会的会服。对。是的，她绝对不是在赞美时尚。但还有一个更深层的维度，多米尼克，
and I know how much you love discussion of transubstantiation. Oh, my word. Your face drops so people who listen to our episode on the grail may remember that the 12th the 13th and then particularly the 14th century is a period where the sense that christ is literally present in the the bread and the wine which is given to people at the eucharist this is very very kind of powerfully felt and tom yeah could that if i was being very skeptical and reductive as I love to be, is that related maybe to the fact that Europe is suffering such intense food shortages in this period?
我知道你有多喜欢关于“圣餐变体”的讨论。天哪。你的脸都垮下来了，所以听过我们关于圣杯那一集的听众可能还记得，12世纪、13世纪，尤其是14世纪，是一个人们强烈感觉到基督确实存在于圣餐中给予人们的面包和酒里的时期，这种感觉非常非常强烈，汤姆，是的，如果我非常怀疑和片面地看待，这是否与欧洲在这一时期遭受如此严重的食物短缺有关？
Yes. In the Grail episode, I talked about the kind of, there were various, and there were always women who were able to live solely off the Eucharist, it was said. And there was this idea that the fact that christ is present in the bread means that it is the ultimate form of sustenance and that's why you know catherine does this as well there are times where basically she's eating nothing except the eucharist yeah so all that stuff in the opening passage about you know drink his blood that sounds vampiric to us for catherine to eat and drink Christ is to know him. So she is experiencing Christ in a kind of multiple number of ways with her mind, but also with her senses. She's tasting him. She is feeling him. And she feels this absolutely vividly. push this to extremes that men can't because the idea that you can marry christ you know this is something that nuns have yeah this is something that men can't do so men have this they definitely have this sense that even though women are subordinate in medieval society that
是的。在圣杯那一集中，我谈到了各种情况，而且总是有女性能够仅靠圣餐生活，据说如此。有一种观点认为，基督存在于面包中这一事实意味着它是终极的维持生命的形式，这就是为什么你知道凯瑟琳也这样做，有时她基本上除了圣餐什么都不吃。是的，所以开篇段落里关于“喝他的血”的所有内容，对我们来说听起来像吸血鬼，但对凯瑟琳来说，吃喝基督就是认识他。所以她正在以多种方式体验基督，用她的思想，也用她的感官。她在品尝他。她在感受他。而且她感受得非常生动。把这一点推向极端，男性无法做到，因为你可以嫁给基督的想法，你知道，这是修女们有的，是的，这是男性做不到的，所以男性有这种感觉，他们绝对有这种感觉，即使女性在中世纪社会中处于从属地位，
very subordination the fact that their bodies are primed, as men see it, for marriage to men, for childbirth, for submitting to men, that in a sense, this gives them an elevated understanding of Christ. It kind of hardwires them for the experience of the supernatural, the, particularly understood this. So I suspect that this is why Catherine becomes a Dominican. The Dominicans understand that Christ says the last shall become first, that there is a kind of power in the subordination of women. And this is the great paradox of Christianity. It's the paradox that Nietzsche many centuries later will pick up on. And it's a paradox I think that's very evident now. The idea that to be subordinate, to be weak, to be inferior relative to those who have status is itself a source of power. If you are a victim, then you can leverage that to attain a status that is greater than those who are not victims. That would never happen in the 21st century, Tom. Right. But this, I think, is why it's so interesting that Catherine seems a figure who is so remote from us and so alien and all this, the language in which she's expressing it
那种从属地位，即她们的身体被男性视为是为了嫁给男人、为了分娩、为了服从男人而准备的，在某种意义上，这赋予了她们对基督更崇高的理解。这在某种程度上为她们体验超自然现象提供了基础，特别是理解了这一点。所以我怀疑这就是为什么凯瑟琳成为多米尼克修会成员的原因。多米尼克修会理解基督所说的“最后的人将成为第一”，女性的从属地位中有一种力量。这就是基督教的伟大悖论。这是尼采在几个世纪后会提到的悖论。我认为这是一个在现在也非常明显的悖论。那种认为处于从属地位、软弱、相对于那些有地位的人处于劣势本身就是一种力量来源的观点。如果你是一个受害者，那么你就可以利用这一点来获得比那些非受害者更高的地位。这在21世纪永远不会发生，汤姆。对。但我认为这就是为什么凯瑟琳这个人物如此有趣，她离我们如此遥远，如此陌生，所有这些，她表达这些的语言
is so strange. And yet it is, I think, recognisable. And I think it's what the Pope, when he says she's very kind of verging on arrogance when she writes to me, while simultaneously being very humble, that the humility and the arrogance are kind of intertwined for the Pope. I'm just going to come out and say it. It's so Greta Thunberg, isn't it? And so the fact that Catherine is seen as having married Christ at a time when the world seems abandoned by God, this is what basically is the source of her power because she's kind of literally been absorbed into the flesh of Christ. So the foreskin, the bleeding foreskin that's been put on her hand, this has become part of her body. And she starts to display stigmata, so the marks of the wounds that Christ suffers on her hand. This has become part of her body. And she starts to display stigmata, so the marks of the wounds that Christ suffers on the cross. And there is an absolutely stunning moment that illustrates this. This is a stunning moment. Stunning moment. So Catherine brings herself
如此奇怪。然而，我认为它是可以识别的。我认为这就是教皇所说的，当她写信给我时，她非常傲慢，同时又非常谦卑，对于教皇来说，谦卑和傲慢是交织在一起的。我只想直说。这太像格蕾塔·通贝里了，不是吗？所以，凯瑟琳被视为在一个世界似乎被上帝遗弃的时代嫁给了基督，这基本上是她力量的来源，因为她实际上已经被吸收到基督的肉体中了。所以，放在她手上的包皮，流血的包皮，这已经成为她身体的一部分。她开始显现圣痕，即基督在十字架上受难的伤口痕迹。这已经成为她身体的一部分。她开始显现圣痕，即基督在十字架上受难的伤口痕迹。有一个绝对令人震惊的时刻说明了这一点。这是一个令人震惊的时刻。令人震惊的时刻。所以凯瑟琳让自己
to drink the pus from the diseased breasts of a lay sister. And she really obviously has to kind of screw up her courage to do this. And she does it as a mark of humility. And she says that it is the sweetest thing that she has ever tasted, that it's radiant with the sweetness of heaven. And Christ then appears to her in a vision and offers her the wound in his side. As you have gone beyond what mere human nature could ever have achieved, he tells Catherine after she has drunk this pass yeah so i today shall give you a drink that transcends imperfection any that human nature can provide drawn close to the outlet of the fountain of
去喝一位平信徒修女患病乳房里的脓液。她显然必须鼓起勇气才能做到这一点。她这样做是为了表现谦卑。她说这是她尝过的最甜的东西，它散发着天堂的甜蜜。然后基督在异象中向她显现，并向她提供了他侧面的伤口。在你超越了纯粹的人性所能达到的极限之后，他在她喝下脓液后告诉凯瑟琳，是的，所以我今天将给你喝一种超越人性所能提供的任何不完美的东西，靠近生命的源头，
life raymond writes she fastened her lips upon that sacred wound and still more eagerly the mouth of her soul and there she slacked her thirst. So this is an image of Christ as a mother. You know, he is effectively offering her his breast to drink from. And this becomes one of the favorite images that Catherine repeats over and over again in her letters. But I mean, it's not just Dominic pulling a very Protestant face. It's not just that though, is it Tom? I mean, such an obvious sexual dimension to this, isn't there? No. You don't think there is? It's massively unerotic. There isn't really any erotic quality in her letters or writings at all.
雷蒙德写道，她把嘴唇贴在那神圣的伤口上，灵魂的嘴巴更加渴望地吮吸，在那里她解了渴。所以这是一个基督作为母亲的形象。你知道，他实际上是在提供他的乳房让她喝。这成为了凯瑟琳在信中反复提到的最喜欢的形象之一。但我的意思是，这不仅仅是多米尼克摆出一副非常新教的面孔。不仅仅是那样，对吧，汤姆？我的意思是，这有非常明显的性维度，不是吗？不。你不认为有吗？它是极其非色情的。她的信件或著作中根本没有任何色情成分。
I mean, Catherine's pretty uninhibited in what she writes. So even though she marries him, Christ is not really the bridegroom in her letters. He is the nursing mother. And so I think that that is what's so interesting. Okay. is the nursing mother and so i think that that is what's so interesting okay is that it's almost as though the extremes of suffering that katherine is putting herself through the starvation the the chain around her body all that kind of thing yeah that she is becoming like christ she is suffering as christ suffers on the cross and this is what enables her to be joined with christ
我的意思是，凯瑟琳在写作时非常无拘无束。所以即使她嫁给了他，基督在她的信中也不是真正的新郎。他是哺乳的母亲。所以我认为这才是最有趣的地方。好吧。是哺乳的母亲，所以我认为这才是最有趣的地方，好吧，这几乎就像凯瑟琳让自己经历的极端痛苦，饥饿，身体上的锁链，所有这些事情，是的，她正在变得像基督，她正在像基督在十字架上受难那样受难，这就是使她能够与基督结合的原因。
and she you know she says that this is an option that is open to all humans, that in their suffering they become like Christ. That's in a way the promise of Christianity generally, isn't it? It is, but she makes it very, very vivid for people. This is illustrated in another kind of astonishing episode that she writes about in a letter to Raymond of Capua. It's about a young Perugian who's been working as a papal agent against the interests of Siena. He gets brought to Siena and he gets beheaded. And before the execution, Catherine visits him in prison, comforts him, goes with him to the scaffold.
而且她，你知道，她说这是一个对所有人开放的选择，在他们的苦难中，他们变得像基督。这在某种程度上是基督教普遍的承诺，不是吗？是的，但她让人们非常、非常生动地感受到了这一点。这在她在给卡普阿的雷蒙德的一封信中写到的另一个令人震惊的事件中得到了说明。那是关于一个年轻的佩鲁贾人，他一直作为教皇代理人反对锡耶纳的利益。他被带到锡耶纳，然后被斩首。在行刑前，凯瑟琳在监狱里探望他，安慰他，陪他走上断头台。
She's standing beneath the scaffold. The head kind of gets cut off the body, bumps down the steps. She catches the head and the blood washes her and covers her. She's drenched in his blood. She says again, a bit like the pus that she's drunk, that this is sweet, that it's like the blood of Christ. Bainham writes of this that Catherine craved blood because she craved identification with the humanity of Christ. Catherine understood union with Christ, not as an erotic fusing with the male figure, but as a taking in and a taking on a becoming of Christ's flesh itself. So what do you make of that, Dominic? I don't know what to say, Tom, but I would have stern words with
她站在断头台下。头从身体上砍下来，顺着台阶滚落。她接住了头，鲜血洗刷了她，覆盖了她。她被他的血浸透了。她说，又像她喝过的脓液一样，这是甜的，就像基督的血。拜纳姆对此写道，凯瑟琳渴望鲜血，因为她渴望与基督的人性认同。凯瑟琳理解与基督的结合，不是作为与男性形象的色情融合，而是作为一种摄入、承担并成为基督肉体本身。那么你对此有何看法，多米尼克？我不知道该说什么，汤姆，但如果我被弹射回14世纪，我会严厉地训斥
her parents, frankly, if I was catapulted back to the 14th century. but the thing is dominic her parents i mean you know they struggled and struggled against it yeah and finally they were forced to you know accept that no fair enough fair enough it's easy for me to judge so so there were absolutely were skeptics at the time there were people say in sienna who said well she's not really a donna she's a witch witch, or she's a fraud. And when she goes to Avignon, she goes into a state of spiritual ecstasy, and one of the mistresses of a cardinal takes a hairpin, jabs it in her foot to see if it's true or not. And actually it is, she doesn't. She holds proof against it. Just a quick observation. You said people who think she's a witch or a fraud. Interestingly, you didn't say there are people who think she's not well. That presumably is because that's a 21st century category that they would not have recognized.
她的父母，坦率地说。但问题是，多米尼克，她的父母，我的意思是，你知道，他们挣扎了又挣扎，反对它，是的，最后他们被迫接受了，不，说得有道理，说得有道理，我很容易评判。所以，当时绝对有怀疑论者，锡耶纳有人说，她不是真正的“自由女性”，她是女巫，或者她是骗子。当她去阿维尼翁时，她进入了一种精神狂喜的状态，一位红衣主教的情妇拿了一根发夹，扎进她的脚里，看看这是真是假。实际上是真的，她没有。她持有反对意见的证据。只是一个简短的观察。你说有人认为她是女巫或骗子。有趣的是，你没有说有人认为她病了。这大概是因为那是21世纪的范畴，他们不会认同。
No, it isn't. There are absolutely people who accept that people can be ill. I know I said that. They do have a kind of sense that you can have something that we might call anorexia. They do have that. Or generally mental illness. So they distinguish between people who are, I guess, what we would call anorexic and people who are saintly. Okay. Yeah. They feel that there's a distinction between that and Catherine is definitely on the borders of the saint. Well, I mean, you've got a list here of the people who believe her, who are hardened, ruthless, cold-blooded kind of people, aren't they? Yes. Or are they using her? Of course they're using her. Absolutely. Exactly as people today may use Greta Thunberg or the
不，不是。绝对有人接受人们会生病。我知道我说了。他们确实有一种感觉，认为你可以患有我们可能称之为厌食症的东西。他们确实有那种感觉。或者一般的精神疾病。所以他们区分了我们称之为厌食症的人和圣洁的人。好的。是的。他们觉得这两者之间有区别，而凯瑟琳绝对处于圣人的边缘。好吧，我的意思是，你这里有一份相信她的人的名单，他们是冷酷无情、冷血的人，不是吗？是的。或者他们在利用她？当然他们在利用她。绝对。就像今天的人们可能利用格蕾塔·通贝里或
Green Movement or whatever for their political ends. But they do feel that she is someone who has to be treated with respect and who they are willing to be influenced by. So all the leaders of these various Italian states who she's negotiating with them, she's trying to patch up peace between them, she's serving as their ambassador. So that's going on. But there are also, by this point, by the time that she's, say, become 30, all those free companies from France have indeed spilled over into Italy and they're part of the mix now. So the Wagner groups of the 14th century. Yes, exactly. And the And what's his name?
绿色运动或其他什么来达到他们的政治目的。但他们确实觉得她是一个必须受到尊重的人，并且他们愿意受到她的影响。所以所有这些她正在与之谈判的意大利各国的领导人，她试图在他们之间修补和平，她担任他们的大使。所以这些都在进行中。但到这个时候，到她30岁左右的时候，所有那些来自法国的自由佣兵团确实已经涌入意大利，他们现在是其中的一部分。所以是14世纪的瓦格纳集团。是的，完全正确。还有那个叫什么名字的人？
Prigogine. Evgeny Prigogine. The Prigogine of the 14th century is Sir John Hawkwood, the Englishman who leads the Free Company, the most terrifying Free Company of all. And she writes to him and he's very respectful of her. But of course, the key figure who's influenced by her is the Pope. And when Gregory XI leaves for Rome, it does seem at least in part that he's doing it because he believes that Catherine is a messenger who's been sent to him from God. And this is a key development in the geopolitics of the 14th century in Europe, because actually the return to Rome of the papacy goes horribly wrong because um barely a year after he's returned to rome gregory the
普里戈任。叶夫根尼·普里戈任。14世纪的普里戈任是约翰·霍克伍德爵士，那个领导自由佣兵团的英国人，最可怕的自由佣兵团。她写信给他，他非常尊重她。但当然，受她影响的关键人物是教皇。当格列高利十一世离开前往罗马时，至少在某种程度上，他这样做是因为他相信凯瑟琳是上帝派给他的信使。这是14世纪欧洲地缘政治的一个关键发展，因为实际上教皇重返罗马的过程变得非常糟糕，因为嗯，在他回到罗马仅仅一年后，格列高利
11th is dead and the cardinals then by kind of catastrophic series of misadventures and unfortunate coincidences end up electing two popes one is an italian and one is a particularly murderous aristocrat from geneva And basically, it's an argument, which is kind of turbocharged by the Hundred Years' War, as to where the papacy should be based. Should it be based in Rome? Should it be based in Avignon? The French are obviously backing,
十一世就去世了，然后红衣主教们通过一系列灾难性的不幸事件和巧合，最终选举了两位教皇，一个是意大利人，一个是来自日内瓦的特别嗜杀的贵族。基本上，这是一个争论，在百年战争的推动下，教皇应该设在哪里。应该设在罗马吗？应该设在阿维尼翁吗？法国人显然支持，
they're backing the Genevan Pope, because they want him to go back to Avignon, which he does. Catherine, of course, backs the Italian Pope, who takes the name of Urban, Urban VI, and rallies to his cause. And again, she plays a key role in ensuring that he is able to cast himself as the authentic Pope against all the wealth and power of the French King with his backing for the French Pope. And basically, I think without Catherine's backing, what comes to be called the Great Schism wouldn't have happened. I think that Urban VI would have been kind of jettisoned.
他们支持日内瓦教皇，因为他们想让他回到阿维尼翁，他也确实回去了。凯瑟琳当然支持意大利教皇，他取名为乌尔班六世，并支持他的事业。同样，她在确保他能够将自己塑造为正统教皇，对抗法国国王及其对法国教皇的支持所拥有的所有财富和权力方面发挥了关键作用。基本上，我认为如果没有凯瑟琳的支持，后来被称为“大分裂”的事情就不会发生。我认为乌尔班六世会被抛弃。
But instead, he is able to draw on her support. In fact, in November 1378, he summons all his cardinals to come and listen to Catherine give a talk, which is amazing. This is the daughter of a tradesman addressing the Pope, addressing the cardinals and being listened to. And Urban VI wrote of her, this weak woman puts us all to shame. I call her a weak woman, not to make little of her, but I want to emphasize that she is a woman and belongs to what is by nature the weaker sex. By nature, it is she who should show fear, even in situations where we would feel no danger. But on the contrary, it is she who should show fear, even in situations where we would feel no danger.
但相反，他能够利用她的支持。事实上，在1378年11月，他召集了所有的红衣主教来听凯瑟琳演讲，这太令人惊奇了。这是一个商人的女儿在向教皇演讲，向红衣主教演讲，并且被倾听。乌尔班六世这样评价她：“这个软弱的女人让我们所有人都感到羞愧。我称她为软弱的女人，不是为了贬低她，而是我想强调她是一个女人，属于天生较弱的性别。按理说，她应该是表现出恐惧的人，即使在我们感到没有危险的情况下也是如此。但相反，她应该是表现出恐惧的人，即使在我们感到没有危险的情况下也是如此。”
But on the contrary, it is we who play the coward while she stands undaunted and by her rousing words imparts to us her own courageous spirit. And so again, it's that idea that in weakness is strength, that the last have become first. And Catherine, she embarks on a particularly spectacular process of fasting so she goes it said a month without drinking any water and you know she can't survive this so um she does that in January 1380 um and she ends her total fast in February but by April she's dead her body can't really cope with it yeah so she's only 33 years old and then she's canonized immediately she becomes a saint no so her body is kept in Rome, where it still lies,
“但相反，是我们表现得像个懦夫，而她却站得坚定不移，用她那激动人心的话语向我们传达了她自己的勇敢精神。”所以，这又是那种“软弱中蕴含力量”、“最后的人成为第一”的观念。凯瑟琳，她开始了一个特别壮观的禁食过程，据说她一个月没有喝任何水，你知道，她无法在这种情况中幸存，所以嗯，她在1380年1月做了这件事，她在2月结束了她的全面禁食，但到了4月她就去世了，她的身体真的无法承受，是的，所以她只有33岁，然后她立即被封圣，她成为了一名圣人，不，所以她的身体被保存在罗马，至今仍在那里，
and her head is taken to Siena, where you can still see it. And she's canonized the following century. What an extraordinary story. And she is felt, as she is still felt by many Christians, to be a figure of incredible power. Well, I mean, she was a figure of incredible power in her time. Right. But also the story is an incredibly powerful story, Tom. Yeah, I mean, she was a vigor of incredible power in her time. Right. But also the story
她的头被带到了锡耶纳，在那里你仍然可以看到它。她在下一个世纪被封圣。多么非凡的故事。而且她被许多基督徒仍然感觉到是一个拥有不可思议力量的人物。好吧，我的意思是，她在她那个时代是一个拥有不可思议力量的人物。对。但这个故事也是一个极其强大的故事，汤姆。是的，我的意思是，她在她那个时代是一个拥有不可思议力量的人物。对。但这个故事
is an incredibly powerful story, Tom. Yeah. So are you convinced? I'm disturbed, actually. So one thing I will say, one of the great things about doing this podcast is you will sometimes pitch a subject
也是一个极其强大的故事，汤姆。是的。那么你被说服了吗？我实际上感到不安。所以有一件事我要说，做这个播客的一大好处是，你有时会提出一个主题，
that I think, hmm, that's going to be a bit dry. And then, as has happened today, you do it, Tom. I'm being nice about you for, you know, I mean, I should do this more often. Bless you.
我觉得，嗯，那会有点枯燥。然后，就像今天发生的那样，你做到了，汤姆。我是在说你的好话，你知道，我的意思是，我应该更经常这样做。保佑你。
Bless you. And it's so interesting. But actually actually i find this a very dark story she's a very troubled woman clearly i mean frankly i don't believe that jesus appeared to her in a bedroom and she got married with david playing the liar or whatever he was doing ever the skeptic ever the skeptic but i think it says something fascinating about the 14th century, about what was clearly a very, very troubled, anxious, paranoid time. Yeah. But it also says something quite tragic about her and her family. Do you not think? I mean, it's a dark story.
保佑你。这太有趣了。但实际上，我发现这是一个非常黑暗的故事，她显然是一个非常困扰的女人，我的意思是，坦率地说，我不相信耶稣在卧室里向她显现，她和弹着里拉琴的大卫结婚了，或者无论他在做什么。永远的怀疑论者，永远的怀疑论者。但我认为这说明了关于14世纪的一些迷人的事情，关于那显然是一个非常、非常困扰、焦虑、偏执的时代。是的。但这关于她和她的家庭也说明了一些相当悲剧的事情。你不觉得吗？我的意思是，这是一个黑暗的故事。
It is a dark story. Well, you know, and it's a dark age. Yeah. And I think the fact that she becomes the most celebrated woman of her age tells you quite a lot about the age. It does indeed. Well, Tom, that was absolutely brilliant i really enjoyed that so uh thank you to all of you for listening and um well done tom thank you for coming and uh we'll see you all next time bye-bye bye-bye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
这是一个黑暗的故事。好吧，你知道，这是一个黑暗的时代。是的。我认为她成为她那个时代最著名的女性这一事实说明了那个时代很多情况。确实如此。好吧，汤姆，这绝对太棒了，我真的很喜欢，所以嗯，谢谢你们所有人的收听，嗯，干得好，汤姆，谢谢你的到来，嗯，我们下次再见，再见，再见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》，我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。